To craft delightful details like these,
we'll take a look at the VectorDrawable
and AnimatedVectorDrawable classes.
We'll start by looking at what
VectorDrawable allows us to do,
to understand what we can animate.
VectorDrawable was introduced in
Lollipop and let's you create density
independent images by defining
a series of drawing commands.
It's similar in concept
to SVG on the web.
Here's an example of a VectorDrawable.
It defines a path which has a series
of space separated drawing commands,
which use a subset of the SVG path data
spec to draw lines, curves and so on.
For example, these commands draw
a cross by moving to a point.
Drawing a line to another point.
Lifting and moving to another point.
And drawing another line.
Simple.
Now vectors aren't appropriate for
every kind of image.
You wouldn't want to represent
a person's face with a vector,
for example.
But iconography and simple
illustrations are great candidates.
The vector format provides
density independence,
meaning that the same image
works on any screen density.
When vector support reaches enough
devices, you won't have to explore
assets at multiple different sizes
like we covered in Lesson One.
It also generally produces
a small file size.
But the opportunity to animate all or
parts of the image is what we're
really interested in right now.
The AnimatedVectorDrawable class let's
you animate any property of a part of
set of parts.
Here's a list of what you can animate.
Now, the first five have pretty
standard animation properties.
But having the ability to target
individual elements within the drawable
is quite powerful.
Let's take a closer look at these
last three more unique properties and
the kind of animation they allow.
We can animate the actual path data
itself, allowing you to morph, so
to speak, one shape into another.
Here's a simple example of
changing a tick into a cross.
We can, of course,
combine this with other effects,
such as throwing in a rotate,
to get a little bit fancier.
The restriction when morphing is that
the shapes need to have the same number
of drawing commands in them in order
to interpolate between the two states.
When drawing a path, VectorDrawable
allows you to only draw a portion of it
by trimming the start or end of it.
In this example, we had a path, which is
the handwritten word, Android design.
And animating the trim on it
produces this fun writing effect.
VectorDrawables also support
the notion of clip pass.
That is applying a clip
region to your drawing.
Animating this clip region allows you to
reveal or hide portions of the image.
So in this example we
have an outline heart.
And then on top of that a filled heart.
By applying a clip region to
the filled heart on top and
animating it, we can produce this
filling up and emptying effect.
These were just a few examples of what
you can do with animated vectors.
They're a great opportunity
to make your app feel alive.